I will hurt you for this the day will
come when you think you're safe and
happy and your joy will turn to ashes in
your mouth and you will know the debt is
paid get out the youtubers is Charlie
this is going to be a Lannister season 7
Game of Thrones video because there are
a lot of reunions that have been teased
that are going to be happening in season
7 the Lannisters coming together again
is going to be one of the other big ones
so just careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened so far so the
really interesting thought is that we're
going to have a Lannister version of the
Battle of the bastards
only not so much bastard in the literal
context as they are all the children of
Tywin and Joanna Lannister more in the
metaphorical context but you have Tyrion
coming with Daenerys and her forces they
will try to sack King's Landing
eventually and Jaime is still with
Cersei albeit with a growing sense of
fear and reluctance so it sounds like we
might get another version of this scene
here where Jon Snow and Sansa meet with
Ramsay Bolton like Tyrion meets his
brother and sister again on the fields
of battle although I don't know that
Cersei would necessarily ride out to a
meeting like that he would probably be
meeting with Jaime so it's not quite the
same thing but Cersei is definitely the
Ramsay Bolton in this equation but even
though it seems like Jaime might hate
his brother for what happened like the
chaos that was caused in the wake of
killing Tywin at the end of season 4 I
don't think that he hates Tyrion the way
that he said he does you get this real
sense that he's fighting his connection
to Cersei especially when you see the
look on his face when he rides into
King's Landing seeing the great set blow
up like oh my god I have no idea what's
going like he just has absolutely no
idea what so she's gonna do next
so he's questioning that whole mess but
I can see where they would want to have
that meeting between Tyrion and Jaime
where Jamie feels obligated to fight
Tyrion and Tyrion feels obligated to
fight Jaime but neither of them want to
do it so you have this amazing character
arc for Jaime's character like he starts
out is like the star quarterback who
just comes to the realization that life
is more than he thinks it is like he's
that stereotypical antagonist
an 80s movie like he's one of those
Cobra Kai people and Karate Kid and then
Tyrion Danielson defeats him and at the
end of the movie he completely questions
his beliefs and kind of turns into a
good person but then you have Cersei
who's like no mercy in our dojo
so you can imagine the direction that
Jaime and Cersei are headed but make no
mistake Jaime always cared for Tyrion he
just treated him in a really shitty way
every once in a while like he was always
listening to his father Tywin like his
father Tywin would give him orders
especially the incident with Tyrians
first wife that was really Tywin's doing
more than Jaime's but Jaime was
complicit in it so you have to imagine
at that point in his life Jaime is still
caving to the pressures of the group
rather than doing what he knows is the
right thing to do
I think on the other side of that Tyrion
cared about both of his brother and
sister at least up until recently with
Cersei and even though Tyrion gave that
epic speech to Cersei where he talked
about joy turning to ash in her mouth
which is especially more telling now
that we have dragons in the equation I
know everyone's hoping for our literal
interpretation of that literal ash from
Dragon Fire in Circe's mouth but Cersei
I think is the one who never cared about
Tyrion at any point she treated him
shittily her whole life and never cared
about him
whereas Jamie did shitty things to him
but still cared about him so let me know
in the comments do you think that we're
going to get a version of the Battle of
the bastards only with the Lannister
children and it'll be like Tyrion versus
Jaime meeting in this moment here with I
guess you could say Daenerys being the
little bear just like scowling from
behind Tyrion just because Tyrians the
one that's going to be talking to his
brother but if they do that how do you
think that that would go down for Jaime
I think that Circe's fate was written
the moment she blew up the great set
even if she makes it to season eight
Lannisters always pay their debts and I
have a feeling she's going to make some
Faustian bargain with Joran that's going
to bite her in the ass maybe literally
but there is still a small chance for
Jaime to survive but I have a feeling it
would involve him turning tail and
running to Daenerys whether or not he
brings any forces with him it really
depends on how tragic you think Jaime's
character is like will he ever get any
moment with Brienne will he ever be
viewed as anything other than the
Kingslayer because if you think he's a
really tragic character then he would
achieve that satisfaction but it would
only happen in a moment that led to his
ultimate death so really I guess it just
depends on how hopeful you think Game of
Thrones is because there are moments of
hope like we have the idea that maybe
Gendry will reunite with Arya that's a
very hopeful moment even if they both
end up dying by the end of the series so
really I think the wild-card here when
we're talking about Lannister children
fighting each other is Jaime I think we
know pretty much what sir she's going to
do and what Tyrion is going to do both
of them are going to do whatever it
takes to win the battle but there is a
new round of the giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video it's just
a $20 Amazon gift card so what's going
to happen next is I know the Emmys are
tonight I'm sure Game of Thrones is
going to win a bunch more Emmys it's
already one more Emmys than almost
anything else in history but they just
announced that Margot Robbie is
officially going to be developing the
Harley Quinn spin-off movie from Suicide
Squad so I'll do a video for that later
tonight so Harley Quinn badass [ __ ]
come in in a little while while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for that Arya Gendry video and you can
click here for like the first couple of
minutes from agents of shield episode
one that's premiering on Monday thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you